have you ever been a wingman and how
good a wingman are you I'm a pretty good
wingman are you yeah wingman you want
I've been a wingman a bunch of times
I got three younger brothers yeah but
then yeah I'm not that bad I'm giving
myself too much credit I'm okay at it
I've seen your brother's before I think
they they do okay you to a few premieres
have you ever gone anywhere in disguise
yeah loads of times yeah I do it all the
time we were at Comic Con recently and I
walked around stano's we were where do
we go recently we were two Browns game
and I wore a big wig and a hat and
sunglasses
yeah I've worn disguises a few times
it's actually really fun to do okay how
much fun was it working on an animated
film and how often did you guys get to
work together action it's really
interesting actually because you spend
so much time working with each other but
you never meet so today we'll and I was
the first time you'd ever met
no for real so it's been it's been a
really really crazy process it's been a
lot of fun I've been kind of working on
this film in between other movies so
it's been a crazy crazy job but I'm so
glad we're finally here and people
finally get to see it so that is strange
though that you're working off this
voice that you hear but you kind of
don't get a chance to put a face to it
well I know the face it's Will Smith you
hear his voice I'm like oh I know what
Will Smith looks like but uh good night
it was a strange process and I feel like
I know him because I've been working
with him and hearing his voice the last
two years but I'm sure we'll be fast
friends and it'll it'll be great
[Music]